rejection Ninja Turtles
yeah we're gonna watch Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Mutant Mayhem today John and Andrew
they watched TMNT the animated flick from
many years ago I did a watch with Aaron Alexander
for the Michael Bay produced ones but he already
saw this one in the theaters scab and it's
the three of us today and I'm excited to check
this out because I hear great things about
it and you bring a witty comment I've said
it before and I'll say it again man I love
being a part of citizen of the rejection Ah
that's a call back that's a callback I love
a Good callback you know what I also like
I like when people realize that it was Greg's
birthday this week and what is the best present
you can give Greg this week especially after
he just went to Urgent Care over the weekend
his birthday weekend what's he doing he's
using his birthday and pity like the ultimate
YouTuber to tell you guys about our new merch
shop reject nationshop.com that's right guys
we have left Zero edition and now all of the
merch like this shirt right here's the space
babies one our new a soda inspired shirt all
of our real rejects merch is going to be going
over there and then we got a new artist on
board my sister it's gonna be some awesome
new designs that we have coming up or I'm
telling you it's going to be great it's one
of the best ways to support the channel and
help pay for my urgent care bill milking the
pain ladies and gentlemen leave a like on
this video and also um hey uh another reminder
full interaction watch long recent with your
own copy of TMNT muted Mayhem available for
super sexy rejects over at our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined cover several
things exclusive for their action highlights
and watch logs included but go to rejectnation
shop.com as well let's get to it
[Music]
love a good stylized bumper cool Greg pictures
I love that production company name already
winning you over listen up we're going after
Dr Baxter Stockman it stole billions of dollars
worth of research and created an actual mutant
mutant wow each of you has been issued a high-powered
anti-mutant neutralizer anti-mutant neutralizer
the minikin who works against the turtles
yeah bring me Stockman's mutant and whatever
he used to I love how it's oozed and green
stick them like a stuck Stockman [Music]
if you like the drawing yeah they're using
like pencil Strokes for even light I perfected
the Ooze are you excited for Daddy I Superfly
we're safe now soon I'll make you brothers
and sisters Carlo it's all our characters
Bebop Rocksteady Mondo Gekko I'm creating
a family Bebop Rocksteady give them the compound
V already [Music]
[Music]
oh
too late oh cool it's like a horror movie
right now yeah it's very Gothic
damn oh my God
Jeff Goldblum [Music]
this is straight up like a horrible dude yes
[Music]
talking about I love that there's like a 80s
90s animation style to this yeah because people
always liking it into the spider verse in
the trailers but I'm definitely getting more
like an 80s 90s type of drawing style like
when it was created in 84 I believe it feels
like you're watching a movie some kids sketched
in their notebook yeah [Music] and thus the
turtles were created
not bad logo not bad
that's pretty cool cool the heavy metal logo
red and orange outline you know like pizza
sauce and pizza crust
Michelangelo
Leonardo Raphael
Donna Phillip
let's go
I loved when camera tracks them like that
it's so fun
we must use stealth and cunning to infiltrate
the human world and retrieve Gogurt hell yeah
Donny you're on toiletries Raph you're stocking
up the pantry and Mikey you're on juncus and
remember don't let any human see you here
[Laughter]
let's go
somewhere you have bronchitis did they record
with all the teenagers in in the same booth
I think it sounds like yeah yeah I think they
did that's just way too natural it's like
Tom Cruise Mission Impossible
nice yeah
[Music] gotta build up Get Swole parents Citywide
are calling for a curfew until the criminal
is caught but the only lead is a mysterious
Mastermind known on the streets as super blocks
so no Shredder this movie okay or maybe you
bought from Rock City will be here or it could
be an Easter egg there's an outdoor movie
night in Brooklyn yeah yeah I hope it's a
funny one hopefully it's better than Tremors
because I know Raphael didn't like that one
well done
Ferris Bueller oh wow that this is a choice
yes huh is this High School like in real life
yeah you go to high school you can just hijack
a parade whenever you want same questions
we asked when we watched it [Music] oh Leo
wants a goth GF this is really interesting
so they're like really yearning for human
connection one day everyone will love us like
everyone loves Ferris Bueller
it tells me this is going to nail about self-acceptance
[Music] stay hidden it's actually doing a
really good job at capturing that teenage
loneliness yeah because they're not even like
looking upon adult they're not even looking
up on other teenagers looking upon like adults
actually and I know what that feels like as
a teenager to have that feeling I make white
noises that makes it louder boys where have
you been it's old
a Jackie Chan yeah yeah look we're really
sorry Splinter some of the guys want to see
a movie and I try to talk them out of it
worst leader will remember why human not disgusting
monsters why they're gonna milk us for our
blood we don't even have nipples [Laughter]
[Music]
let's take it as an odd way to phrase
it all started 15 years ago it's much urgent
I was young red in my 20s I was on top of
the world we have one friend he was a cockroach
we got along very well his name was a campus
was it Kevin Eastman everything changed
oh so adorable I really love the animation
I love the art behind this a lot whatever
this proves was he transformed us
that's so cool like seeing the actual transformation
I became older red you guys were babies so
you stay baby you look like Squirtle yeah
and then they'll evolve into war tortol we
became a family [Music] oh hell yes greetings
girl and welcome to my world I like your there
is such a youthful quality the way they drew
this movie really feels like teens put it
together it happened the most complimentary
way yeah like a finessed version of it
when you think about like he's got to take
care of four kids by himself it's not easy
he's a single dad yeah no and I like how they're
really capturing him being a father not just
a Sensei yeah yeah as a matter of fact how
does he become a martial artist he's a survivalist
so he learned you were obsessed with the human
world so I decided to give her a shot oh no
no stay down there okay that guy's gonna have
to learn to accept risks [Music] wow oh my
God they are so adorable yeah I want plushies
of each of them in baby form they are so cute
[Music] oh no it didn't go well oh my God
Paramount oh yeah Nickelodeon [Music] jeez
guys terrible oh look at the adorable turtles
[Music]
oh that day I promised to never let you get
hurt ever again I needed to find a way to
unlock ancient secrets of ninjutsu okay weapon
of death and I found it okay he learned from
this yes [Music] oh I got it let's just learn
from Cinema television this is great
whoa oh my God so many classic Kung Fu films
[Music]
we only need each other you boys are all I
got and you're all I'll ever had dude Jackie
Chan's killing the voice working yeah no leave
to soar for one month seriously yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I made up my mind are you gonna
get food uncle
I just gotta get out of the sewer man I mean
I like you guys and all but I just simply
cannot live a happy life knowing that your
faces are the last things I'm gonna see before
I die good cheese that's fair the time actually
changed the Colossus never see that happen
Target's approaching [Music]
The Dark Knight yeah [Music]
I love this music who did the score I don't
know but it every choice is very transported
for the exact mood and moment [Music]
oh
I will say the street stuff does remind me
a lot of the spider-verse movies [Music]
that is sick I was like they gotta call him
Superfly for some reason damn strong enough
to hold an ice cream truck get three people
in it
now that's a hell of a hideout yeah jealous
I just love how disproportionate like some
of the facial features are of people yeah
ah is he eating them I don't I seems like
it so they stole a radioactive storage unit
this time put tracking devices on all shipments
yeah yeah stay still gonna go viral viral
Ninja Turtles awesome come on guys we just
got ungrounded all right let's go home is
it weird to have your head so far up Dad's
butt yo check this out in slo-mo whoa Fruit
Ninja he's gonna die hey why do we pick a
fruit shaped exactly like my head your head
looks like Scooby at a baby with Hey Arnold
yep that's funny it's a deep reference
was that April O'Neill it was [Music] it's
a good thing she was wearing a helmet I know
murdered her oh what's her deal she's yelling
at us on blocks I think she's mad that we
hit her with the ninja star I think she's
asking Leo on a date I think the lady behind
you
your scooter you gotta be heroes now we tried
to Warner nothing more we can do
gotta get the scooter back to this beautiful
and Charming human one
prove yourself
I I am genuinely loving this movie yeah hasn't
missed a beat so far we're gonna need the
most foolproof plan every single ninja technique
all right I need you guys to use stealth to
block the doors you say it going loud [Laughter]
that's a lot of guys oh you got some ass whooping
to do you could take them we've prepared our
whole life for this I've actually been in
a fight oh no you noticed but all I've got
is a big stick oh my God this is great I dream
about fighting every night you got a rage
that's not a problem
uh oh my God oh my God I'm glad it wasn't
the nunchucks it's always the nunchucks it's
got shades of Ace Ventura when he got the
thing stuck in his legs
you say they look like sharks at one point
was that Street Sharks reference oh come on
Leo delegate
all right we gotta work as a team guys oh
I love capturing them on their first fight
yeah they're so unorganized right now
woo go ninja go ninja go
did not think we'd be hearing that song again
ninja rap we all love vanilla ice walk softly
Donatello [Music]
woof
yeah my goodness oh
yeah this guy would have been great in Tokyo
Drift [Music] that was by the books really
well done
I I feel like really connected to them yeah
like my heart feels like really connected
to this you got my scooter back so I feel
like Donna you go on first you're the most
inviting impressive
his work isn't
easy those are taken sharks uh there's wolves
up for grabs wow the costumes are Street Sharks
how do you get this on and off that's your
skin
can we explain this over some pizza how you
guys feel about pepperoni yeah he hasn't red
onions for me what about you guys just choose
on a pizza with another Pizza on top of the
pizza Mutant baby turtles to turtle men guys
uh Turtle boys actually I would say teens
you know I would say Turtleman teenagers teenagers
call them the thing do it you guys are TMNT
I write for my school paper really I assume
you'd want to be on camera because you have
like a very camera ready look oh my smooth
my guy the police have been talking about
implementing this curfew if they don't find
him soon right I'm trying to you know help
bring into justice so everyone could chill
out or whatever but this do you think there
are more people like you you know people who
will accept us oh my gosh no no absolutely
not but they can monetize you yeah I'll airdrop
you my contact and if you ever feel like you
wanna come out to the world or whatever just
let me know like how she's at least respectful
about what the hell of her whole personality
man Iowa debris give me that contact Pizza
Hut yes I think there was a giant commercial
about pizza before the VHS of the first film
if I remember correctly I hope you're [__]
right angry
well there was dominoes in the first movie
Roy's Pizza in the second movie what if everyone
saw says hero I mean look
[Music]
it's like Coke and Avengers end game sure
he's a giant terrifying green monster but
everyone knows he saved them so they're taking
subies with them in a diner yeah hello mostly
improvised that scene I know he's good on
his feet
I love how much they consume media yeah what
about that though he doesn't really need to
know about it and you help us find Superfly
we bring him to Justice you document it all
prom is uncanceled and we get accepted by
the world as Heroes wow wow
they have fears okay perfect yes how about
we meet tonight 8 PM Eastman High yeah for
Kevin Eastman [Music]
love how alive the city is too whole thing
I like how they're capturing the underlying
sadness behind the turtles very well too yeah
[Music]
Eastman the relationship forming with April
is great I think it's wonderful is this uh
living up to your dreams
Attack on Titan attack on Titus
ever look oh my God oh my God do we not have
last names it's okay I'll just break it up
Michael Angelo Perfecto that makes you Leonardo
uh wolf man's got nard that reference Monster
Squad hey well at least I'm not puke girl
that is a bat oh is that April is that April's
Locker I thought I could read the morning
announcements and you know it didn't go so
well oh no oh no [Music] who would be on camera
anxiety exciting me feel like I was gonna
explode and so well you didn't I did
oh my God The Secret of the Ooze I was about
to say that you beat me to it oh
my God remix I was gonna say that's not something
anyone forgets in high school I hope we get
to see the turtles do improv it's all the
personalities feel so relatable and distinct
Superfly seems to be building
so that's awesome nobody's ever seen his face
why because he kills everyone who does oh
maybe he's trying to rescue his brother and
sisters in their crew sure Sharon Paul Bronson
tubei Tom and normal Nate let's start chasing
him down I like to play I wish my high school
had a dark room yeah
[Music] great Montage
oh hell yes yes let's get an older boy reference
love that they're actually using their weapons
calling you out [Music]
I mean they're just straight up Vigilantes
they're not doing any ninja [__] teenage
vigilante ninja Vigilantes
God man these these match cuts are freaking
awesome
yeah
I love how Ralph's teenage rage is like a
fun bloodlust of a teenager oh this radioactive
storage unit but so let's just love however
the chest hair looks like this yeah the deal
with Superfly is tonight under the bridge
we give him his unit and he leaves us alone
the villainous Menace really does remind me
of like Kingpin from spider-verse just the
tone of it that it emits hey I'm a Gangster
I got my puff in my Timbs I need my bacon
egg and cheese too you got the good Superfly
[Laughter] [Music]
you're you're uh-oh text from Dad well they
say Dad not Master Splinter like it hits home
a lot more surprise you want to be in the
human world and I found your human clothes
I think I maybe found a way to make you happy
I brought the human world to you look no
what are you doing up there don't lie tell
me is someone trying to milk you uh do you
need help anything you need I'm here we're
just running errands I hope in the post-credits
scene they're getting milked yes
all right well hey thanks for the surprise
party appreciate it Dad we will be leaving
goodbye no no [Music] Ali smutter suffers
from cardiac arrest and they just weren't
there for any of it yeah it feels like Mad
Max yeah where's the Dew for here all right
guys there's two cars in the motorcycle it's
like 10 dudes Tops This is just dragging the
back into that car on the ground speed Bob
rock city is it oh yeah super slapio damn
nipple ring yeah my man I can milk you
there he is my man we're here to find you
I can't believe there are other mutants like
us oh this is so good 15 years ago right some
sludge was dumped in the sewer and y'all came
from that well we prefer the term ooze but
yeah just like when the professor explained
that to them in the second Turtles movie that
same ooze made me my dad Baxter Stockman he's
the one who dumped the Ooze down the drain
baby so technically we cousins Ice Cube yeah
it's Ice Cube this is Bebop and that's Rock
stick hey what you looking at yeah bro what
you looking at right here we got Wing nuts
High Wing wave we got it [Music] this is leather
head oh I get right fellas Genghis frog hey
that scumbug she only speaks
that's Mondo Gekko hey what's up what's up
Bros I like your Vibe digging your Vibe I
ship them do you recognize that voice he's
an adventure thank you oh Paul Rudd yeah what
are you building if we gonna chat let's go
somewhere fun yeah okay I think it's such
a great flip yeah please tell me they're gonna
play Turtles in Time that'd be amazing they're
supposed to be versus fighting each other
and it's turning into bonding I mean they
can't they can't relate to each other they've
all come from the same thing so when they're
trying to find Community among people and
finding community in a whole other place yeah
it makes sense yo check this
oh yes maybe you could finish explaining like
exactly where you came from and what you want
and stuff oh easy acceptance they want the
same thing my earliest memory in the world
is one day telling me it was accepted he just
wanted a family man oh this whole story is
about acceptance yeah but then that's when
the people we work for sent the obstacle they
took it from Ops I rescued my little baby
brother and sister and since I was the oldest
you know I had to raise them you did a great
job you did damn it's like a splinter in himself
it's like real life in some cases maybe they
just ain't all bad we went out we hit the
town and it did I love how personal they're
making this and now it's like a reflection
of the turtles it's so good he wouldn't stop
chasing us he wanted to kill us oh my God
that's what happened no okay she's a hockey
sticker yeah I beat that fool damn I touched
that cheese
that is a great expression to kill all the
humans rule the Earth whatever I built a machine
to enact my plane damn I get where he's coming
from though then we're gonna launch it into
the atmosphere and watch it vaporize turn
everyone into the lizard I was thinking I
was just thinking that yeah
they would get their acceptance the turtles
that they want we wish there was another way
to feel safe and happy but people's they got
to go
I got this I can complete my device in acceptance
dominance will be yours you stopping them
now you're gonna make me film you
oh you can finally have family and friends
what if we're not into the plan I don't agree
what if we don't like it and that right there
pissed me off
oh it's not real acceptance we'll drive the
van with the storage unit and uh you lead
the way so mind the wing nut Rock ride with
the tortoise [Music] it's interesting Bebop
and rockstead are just animals too like they
didn't they weren't first humans
a lot of them no it might be buffing even
Superfly has Baxter Stockman right yeah yeah
I changed that here too it's go time
in their device that's small enough to get
under the seat but strong enough to press
the pedal you mean a stick I got it a bow
bow staff
like I was doing like a pool stick yeah [Music]
karaoke's always fun
[Music]
it's like wanted yeah oh yeah good call
remix oh can they convert this into their
Turtle van I'll probably get the numb chucks
on the Turtle van now don't worry guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music] I understood that reference it's from
Superman right Superman Begins
pressure my guy whoa jeez [Music]
maybe that won't be the turtle then and the
good thing is they know the location no [Music]
go go game guy from the beginning he's got
a grudge or they had a tracking remember they
said they put tracking units on everything
April hell
abandoned by humans now you know April's gonna
bust them out nah she's out of the movie April
gang gonna do [__] she's gonna turn into
Megan Fox yes and then leave I've been looking
for you for a long long time I don't know
what you want from us or why you talk so scary
there's a fly monster I'm gonna do the talking
it kind of has krang's colors I am Cynthia
rose colors April's colors I will use you
to create a stable mutagen an army of super
soldiers she's pretty bad herself [Music]
there it is closed captioning not available
[Music]
smooth like
butter come on guys
voice kind of sounds like Jake Gadsden wait
Jake Johnson oh yeah someone's here Peter
B Parker
stay back I just care for my boys lie to me
they're in so much trouble right now oh is
that so Ratatouille I was thinking right too
oh God laughs
oh it's like an actual plasma
you're finding your calling [Music] a lot
of us like a Jackie Chan fight yeah totally
I wonder if he had input on the choreographer
I'm sure he did
team no no no no
yeah [Music] oh that's awesome it's amazing
nice yeah get some nunchuck action and somebody
else got hit in the nuts not the wielder that
was great that was so satisfying right funnel
moment loved it how did you find it I'd be
a pretty big piece of crap if I didn't at
least try to get your dad to come help you
oh
11 Hopper and our four boys yeah let's get
on those bikes kids there's only one way for
you to be safe and happy and just listen to
me let's go it's hitting deep right now just
the always lost moment starting another song
seeing you guys make so many mistakes just
to get people to like you made me realize
I was definitely doing this for the wrong
reason hey okay sometimes you never learn
okay do this channel for so many years sometimes
that's life and then all I see is one or two
comments that it becomes a goal to get those
two people to like me acceptance at any cost
what is it about humans that you love so much
if we kill them we are no better than they
are I refuse to accept that you all are cool
with brutally killing all of them no no Superfly
is gonna stay constant though sometimes you
know
everyone on Earth Superfly is definitely not
changing fools no we don't want to do this
we just didn't know that there was any other
alternative but we see that there is let's
uh right you want to stop this machine
oh no I just keep doing a great job yeah everybody
man this is really well cast [Music] Sky beam
It's gotta say that reminds more of Mr Freeze's
ice gun Batman and Robin I think he's the
reason we gonna do [Music] something damn
it's so weird to say rock steady and Bebop
on the good team
man up
[Music]
everyone just attacked at once [Applause]
if you listen to me the error of my ways yeah
[Applause] [Music] oh man
crushed to death
I think Kaiju fly yeah the opposite at the
Lazarus Pit
ah Jurassic world Dominion or Godzilla sure
oh God Wowie [Music]
whoa I love how you can feel the weight of
it just struggling to get up yeah look at
my feet
wow they really Cronenberg
wow oh that is horrifying I love it I don't
want to be like Superfly I want you to be
happy even though I don't like humans I want
them to like you oh we're gonna take him down
we're gonna film it we're gonna show it to
you tomorrow and the world will love you and
accept you and where would you turtles turtles
turtles oh what happened to the whole stop
Superfly thing are we not doing that or what's
up so much has changed since we lost spoke
I love when they're Heroes for stopping the
problem they helped create yeah love that
trip I actually might have something oh right
the anti Mutual mutagen gun it's a covered
parallel
let's leader ever Leonardo
nice teaming up it's like a whole superhero
Team Four
it's nice yeah nice so Neil the hero shot
puke [Music] all right close one eye I heard
that hell [Music] I mean come on it's not
really gonna do anything
what the hell we're good right
I don't need that horse
you gotta go inside his mouth and shoot him
yeah you gotta fill his belly up with the
stuff damn love the explosions I think we
lost them
how
oh man I love this dread Heavy Music it's
a drowning bass rampaging through downtown
New York the only question is do we capture
them for experimentation or kill them on site
oh God mutants are attacking the city
I'm not the big Superfly be a military response
oh that's really sad is this the world you
want to protect you got to protect it even
if it doesn't understand I think we're monsters
I hope this takes a different ending and they
just start slaughtering humans you know what
we were wrong I know we only wanted to be
heroes to be accepted but even though it looks
like we'll never be accepted I still think
we should try to be heroes what I mean yeah
guys it's a real hero right there I'm sorry
I shouldn't have should have protested that
Attack on Titan giant monsters attack and
they have one weakness in the backs of their
necks the ball is exactly that there it is
Attack on Titan is the only manga I read it's
time to go loud loud real loud
yeah she sounded like a leader I actually
was a literally agreeing
Lord this helmet was a good investment yeah
it's not for that helmet she would have perished
very early on in the film change the narrative
keep rolling rolling she's on camera
this movie's about facing your fears swallow
it April O'Neil here reporting live with new
and confirmed information a fly monster is
attacking the city you just need to find something
bigger than yourself to fight for they would
definitely just let you do the news a random
teenager against the monster in an attempt
to save the giant monsters man but the mutants
you see here are in fact good it's okay
you think the same language as scumbag we
actually have a lot in common oh my God
[Music] the
fours playing Forza really helped Donnie with
his driving yeah he'll direct the forza movie
[Music]
wow
he's so old [Music]
wow you know now that we're actually about
to die there's nothing I'd rather be looking
at oh oh I love the details on Donny's frames
come on save your boys damn I love how gritty
this shit's getting
[Music] who's this guy he's gonna help hey
are you okay do you need help someone's actually
helping I must get this to my boys I got this
let's go New Yorkers [Music]
you do not know New York Delivery Man they
have a common enemy this is just like Watchmen
now to unite the world in peace to this tragedy
this is very well coordinated I love it [Music]
taxi cab guy too that kickflip nice grind
[Music]
everyone is so in sync [Music]
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work dude you left
the size in there oh [__] oh God this
would have been so cool in 3D
yes oh got him hell yeah yeah
oh the horses [Music] cute titles
ninjas my ninjas
fill up another one big happy family
not sad at all that they had to kill their
big brother who raised them oh we're getting
ready for school that's a very different direction
for the turtles their sewers all over the
city just hop in the store you can come home
oh it's better than the subway Teenage Mutant
Ninja high school I want to see that I'm proud
of you boys I love you we love you love you
too
oh wow wow how are we gonna know who's who
[Applause]
yeah yeah thanks for saving us guys
what a cool mirroring from the beginning to
the end here oh hey bro Heroes [Music] boss
lady well done fantastic terrific that was
fantastic man definitely a different direction
but oh that was the animated series that was
awesome David Fincher directed this hey hello
it's Tony and I have found my people the it
Club welcome to my Australian shoe store do
you have any Nikes no but I do have the Australian
version
Leo how many times
who is tcri
[Music]
oh my God they're going to prom tuxedo t-shirt
this is such a different direction I love
it oh you guys should get together it is what
Baxter who is it [Music] yes
capturing them on the other hand might prove
difficult there is one option [Music]
I'm so excited I cannot wait to see that oh
my god oh okay this definitely sounds like
a Trent rezner beat you're wrong it's not
changing chance but I did I didn't think it
sounded like him though and they're all like
actual kids yeah yeah the kid the the turtles
are for sure alrighty alrighty we got 20 minutes
to chat I'm going to fill up this entire time
everyone Joy go first Andrew I really enjoyed
it like I said it was a different take on
what plenty John no no go ahead it was it
was a different take on what uh we're used
to seeing I love the whole theme of acceptance
it was something I think we all relate to
I mean I'm still trying to gain Acceptance
in this world because good luck being you
everyone hates me everyone says I'm a reference
machine it still doesn't like me
but also too I mean we know also you know
just like coming back even to like Splinter
yes he's always been a father figure and they're
Sensei and all that but like you'll never
be accepted it really hit a lot deeper on
this because I mean just little things in
this like yes again he always felt like a
father figure in the movies in the TV show
but like that like little things like them
actually calling him dad and stuff like that
and then like Leo wanting to have a romantic
interest and then that with April I mean there
were just so many little things that I just
was like getting so invested in and I love
the the animation and and I mean there were
other things too I wasn't expecting like there
was like levels of horror in this too with
like the superfly uh played by Ice Cube very
brilliantly I mean I had like just eating
people and stuff like that and then the whole
plan itself was actually really horrific if
you think about what he was trying to do with
the whole Amazing Spider-Man lizard uh turning
everyone into mutants like that was really
uh scary but I love the whole idea too of
the turtles like having this you know the
juxtaposition of okay look we want everyone
to accept us but like you know and then also
Splinter has been teaching us for forever
like that you know this world is like there's
a lot of evil people out here who will not
accept us and we can turn this whole world
into mutants kind of thing and people will
now or mutants now will accept us that will
be a in a world amongst ourselves and they
make the hard decision they make the hero
decision like no that's not right and I thought
that was really deep and there were a lot
of different other things I like but I don't
want to hog up on you guys go ahead
well you know about who you want to be accepted
by and what you want to be accepted for and
I think that was very exciting it's never
getting accepted never see that's the thing
is I don't surprised you enjoyed this at all
because I don't think you know it'll be ever
possible for you to relate yeah you were like
the turtles in this movie but only the first
like everything before the finale it's like
that news report they had where they were
like surrounded by fire and they looked really
menacing you that's where you're identifying
with it ends right there after that you can't
relate then you're like what is this everyone's
celebrating I don't understand at all I bet
you guys know me so well it's okay Andrew
it's because we don't accept you he is we
don't accept you we judge you we judge and
our judgment is uh correctness that's fine
please I'm sorry um I interrupted you because
this nuisance was talking about us it's okay
it's fine I I appreciate you apologizing on
his behalf uh no I love this from front to
back uh it will probably have a lot of the
similar things to say but yeah this moved
with like an effortlessness of pace it was
so well proportioned it had such a lovely
spirit and especially in the first 10 or 15
minutes it was moving between a lot of different
things but it had a really gradual and very
smooth grip on how to do that there are certain
voices that don't get to speak very much but
on the whole the voice cast is terrific and
just yeah I loved loved what they did with
the animation here because spiderverse has
opened up such a door for what we think of
when we think of a computer animated movie
like this and there is so much love for other
styles of Animation out there and so this
managed to Encompass to take that leap that
spider-verse perhaps presents and do something
kind of its own with it and to hearken I don't
have like the best lexicon of Turtles comics
but having this like scuzzy or more asymmetric
Ice uh asymmetric design style felt kind of
like something I would uh look at in you know
like an old panel from one of those it had
some of that Gonzo quality while still being
very family accessible and uh and just yeah
like so many lovely little choices like all
those scribbly whip pans and like the Halos
of light that feel like just yeah white pencil
scribbles and stuff and and the way they pitted
everybody in a position where they need some
kind of acceptance but they're all approaching
it from different motivations and angles like
this was I I would assert that you know with
a few basic ingredients you can make a satisfying
Turtles movie but they just went Above and
Beyond on everything so yeah I this absolutely
I think deserves to be one of the top movies
of the Year this was so great
Commander uh-huh you want me to continue yes
uh I also like how you might gain our acceptance
just throwing you off for a game all right
um oh God what did you talk about and what
did you talk about and what did I talk about
all right I guess I'll bring theories to the
game here I think I laid out pretty much everything
that I loved about it during the reaction
um and then I'm sure more will come out during
it I feel like this Cynthia utron person my
theory here's my theory does everyone want
to hear my theory what's your theory or accept
it automatically I think praying is inside
of her I think she's a machine that'd be awesome
yeah that would be oh that's a good Theory
actually yes that's mine I accept it very
good that's my theory for that and I like
what they're building up for I mean because
I mean she said she's huge from and just there's
something about the way she was coming granted
everyone kind of had a strange disproportionate
design a lot of the humans looked a little
bit off not all them but some of them did
and I feel like there's something to her specific
physique and Bill that felt a little bit android-like
and there and something about the type of
uh tenor in her voice that specifically sounded
a bit like she was channeling what we kind
of associate with the voice of Krang sure
and that is why I wouldn't go there um and
I love the ominous teas that they have there
at Shredder at the end and give it something
more personal I was surprised by this film
significantly uh I I was really enamored from
it from beginning to end you know I think
out of all the turtles movies this I call
it recency I got a little bit of criticisms
of a couple of things but for the most part
I think out of all the turtles films this
might be up there as my favorite one even
though there's a couple of things I wish that
they did do and a couple of things that wasn't
that didn't click as strong for me as I may
have hoped there's there's some stuff that
I thought the intention was very strong and
I loved the idea and there's a lot of it that
I did like and then there's like other qualities
to it that I was like I just didn't quite
fully 100 hit the mark for me because obviously
the turtles I thought great the camaraderie
the bonding with them was excellent uh Splinter
I I this I I think I think people would have
a lot of gripe with Splinter here uh like
for people who are like fans of Ninja Turtle
because he's like such a dad he's not really
like the ninja background and in fact it's
one of the things about this movie that I
was like there's no real like ninja stuff
yeah and here you know they just straight
up become like Vigilantes and then they're
now accepted in high school and they're receptive
by the world which I love the arc and I love
the trajectory of that and we've seen so much
different kinds of there's there's countless
types of Ninja Turtles properties that I'm
not exactly perturbed uh by that you know
a lot of people wanted to go down the specific
direction that we're all sort of familiar
with and you know there is that Association
of like out of the shadows and whatnot however
I think this direction is very different especially
when it comes to like the film the film medium
for uh the Ninja Turtles I think it's an excellent
direction to go and just something that we
haven't seen before it's kind of like when
um you know Spider-Man's identity getting
revealed at the end of far from home like
oh damn what's this gonna do this is gonna
be like very different and that's Iron Man
and that's a very and I am Iron Man like that
this is a very different type of approach
that I really like uh to to explore here because
it really captures the the heart and soul
of what it's like to be a teenager uh in a
wide variety of areas and it really captures
like the New York Spirit of what I know from
films and the couple of times I've been to
New York you know and the New York pizzas
I have eaten it captures that Flair that eccentricity
and I I love the concept of the of the superfly
family and everything they represented and
especially thematically for how that is a
thematic for what that mirrors with Splinter's
Journey thematically for what that mirrors
for uh the turtles Journey all that there
were just times though where I I did kind
of feel like it needed a uh I think it's because
there was so much heart and soul and so much
layers to the the bonding of the turtles and
then that family was just everyone there was
just kind of one note and it's I know it's
like an animated movie it's an hour and a
half but everyone was just kind of like if
I were to do an impression of all them in
one sentence it'd be I'm the family yeah this
is all the books so you know well because
I know their lines are just during action
so they're saying action lines yeah and like
they were all pretty much like some variation
of Mondo gecko you know sure you know and
and I I did when like Superfly is such a a
a a a nuanced villain and I think a great
villain and I thought that kind of missed
it to the so I I I would have kind of felt
a little bit more of that emotional catharsis
if I felt that they were more real characters
it was the only time when I felt like celebrity
voice cameos where everyone else was just
like pure perfect Talent yeah you know and
that felt like celebrity voice cameos even
Paul Rudd like I enjoyed Mondo Gekko but I
was Paul wrote you know uh so yeah like it's
not like I didn't like them I I just I loved
so I loved the world the aura the tone the
animation everything you guys touched on Splinter
every one of the turtles I loved it all and
then the movie does take time to you know
give a good amount of screen time to this
other family which is very important and Integra
I love the idea of them so much and I do feel
like they kind of miss the emotional beat
Mark which I do feel is an integral part when
it is ending on the note of they are joining
to be one big cohesive one big family down
in the sewers and grow together like it is
a an important aspect to the film and I I
did crave that so that's my that's my one
thing that I'm missing from it but other than
that I do think it is like one of the best
memories I've seen of the year and it is so
really strong and it might be up there as
my favorite I want to revisit the original
1990 Turtles uh I would say those are my two
the 1990 and this one I want to revisit that
one before I make because I I was listening
to a review from red letter media about it
and then I was like you know I really don't
remember this movie
it still holds up for me I love that movie
they were showing scenes I was like I don't
know any of this like I don't remember Jack
about it and so I wanna I know I've seen it
though so I want to revisit it not going to
do a reaction or maybe I don't know uh but
I want to revisit it yeah and before I make
that statement but right now for with like
I remember Secret of the Ooze very well because
for some reason I watch that's more kid-friendly
yes I watch that all the time and I watch
the part three all the time um so I I don't
so I I don't want to say this is my favorite
one but but it's up there it's it's definitely
up there even though they didn't have the
ninja quality it's definitely up there um
yeah I think they could have also used maybe
just a pinch of conflict between the rest
of the family having to go against the guy
who raised them and then afterwards maybe
mourning him a little yeah exactly you know
yeah because there was no there could have
been a they set up such a fascinating debate
like the second the turtles were like oh my
God wait a minute the story is so much about
acceptance and these can be the the uh the
extended family where they could find the
acceptance and it seemed like they had that
room for such an interesting conversation
and but because the rest of the family was
just kind of like just one note yeah I do
agree the way that they got the other family
to flip so quickly on Superfly after years
of him nurturing them and being a family like
damn that was a quick flip like one speech
and you're done with Superfly I'm like again
what Leo and the rest of turtles were saying
like made sense and I I get why they would
change their mind I'm like damn that was yeah
quick you guys just finished your mind and
especially because they established that Superfly
has the intelligence of Baxter Stockman yeah
that he would have the emotional capacity
to be able to instill but then again he is
very like strong yeah he's like he's he's
more imbued in like yeah hatred and revenge
yeah he's probably an emotionally closed off
Father Figure he's probably I mean because
of what he's had to go through and I think
to like the way that they decide ultimately
like oh yeah we don't want to do this is amusing
in the moment I appreciated of course in isolation
but because it's sort of nonchalant and then
everyone's like yeah we don't want to do this
I feel like it does kind of sap again a potential
moment for True conflict emotional and I know
I'm probably gonna get ripped for this but
whatever um but I know the least the least
again I know you guys are gonna be like of
all the things you found to be least believable
in this film a Superfly growing all this I
don't know about April being just allowed
to be alive
I just don't put by it okay half the people
I will set the building yeah I will accept
the camera man yeah exactly uh I will say
well it's because Bruce Wayne called them
and told him to get out of the building um
I will say this though I'm glad and even though
they did address it in the film that was one
of my favorite moments for for Leonardo in
terms of addressing the team and like having
his leader moment because that's one of the
things that has been like especially is such
a big Leonardo stand like God he's such a
terrible leader but I still love him I'm like
and you uh Dressed it you're like Alfred loser
like I've kind of felt that way so many times
when I've watched on Instagram like he's such
a terrible leader yeah but in this film like
and he got his moment but I'm glad they addressed
it in the film like that was such a great
leader moment for you like and but and like
when he addressed the team he he gave that
like he was coordinating on what they needed
to do and he gave the great speech like but
it was like really well earned too like it
didn't yeah it didn't feel like oh here's
the moment it just feels like yeah it was
naturally yeah and I think Jackie Chan I mean
again all the cast was really good other than
I know the point you made about the celebrity
Cameo and stuff but all the turtles Ayo is
April fantastic she was fantastic I love what
Jackie Chan did as Splinter and again the
like you said the different approach they
did with splinter in terms of because from
what we got I remember in the films he was
you know uh um was it a Mata Yoshi's uh Rat
and then that's how he
yeah exactly and then I love too and the way
he was fighting like the really choreographing
that his fights like according to like how
Jackie Chan would fight in real life too was
really like kind of meta in itself as well
but I just again I I really love Kevin Clash
and uh the first two films and then I really
liked Mako and the the film that you uh John
and I reacted to but yeah Jackie Chan just
really like I just really felt the camaraderie
he had with his children it was so endearing
and so cute and so Charming this was the most
emotional I've ever felt towards any towards
the turtles and this and Splinter especially
like I thought the heart just felt so genuine
I cared so much and I was from when I when
I realized that they were like oh this is
their first fight they're gonna have I was
really rooting for them I'm like damn I've
never like rooted so much for these guys on
an emotional Journey before or physical like
I really really care about them as like kids
you know and I've never had that for them
like I've always liked them and of course
I root for them it's just not to this extent
not to this level you know find yourself like
identifying quite as heavily as you do here
yeah yeah I thought everyone made they made
very in April too very very relatable and
like the way they modernize the the friendship
and how that went down and and the way their
their camaraderie formed I was like this is
like believable I'm I'm just super grateful
April was wearing that helmet at the beginning
because this film would have been super short
yeah yeah Teenage Mutant Ninja murderers yes
right great music too as we've kept pointing
out yeah um great cinematography and I can't
wait for the sequel like for that possible
Theory and then obviously we get the great
Shredder um so I think it's great that they
save Shredder you know yeah no I mean we've
seen Shredder done plenty of time so I mean
I feel like they're building up like a joker
in darkness yeah exactly begins with the joker
card here at the end Batman's the hero Gotham
and then now we got Joker yeah yeah and then
now we're doing that here where the turtles
are accepted and loved and now the Shredder's
gonna have to because yeah they you got to
find a way to I mean there's got to be a way
to manipulate because the part of it was like
oh Bebop and Rock City or I didn't hear it
good but I think are they doing something
here where Bebop because I mean the big Association
is be bop and Rock City work for Shredder
so it's gonna somehow we're gonna break up
the family yeah he's got to find some Sinister
way to get in there psychologically to them
I feel like there's a way to like really dark
it up because I what I love too is how gritty
the finale was getting like it was getting
really Grim right now yeah and I like that
I like when the I've I've I've never I can't
recall seeing that it was It was kind of disturbing
when when Superfly is cracking
yeah yeah that was kind of disturbing yeah
and it had a good a good conscientious sense
for when to borrow like you were like oh this
is kind of like a Magneto plan and it's kind
of like this movie or that movie like they
they borrowed from other movies in very conscientious
ways to the point where it's like oh cool
I can clearly see what you're doing but also
it kind of reads like a reference or something
like that and it makes sense it feels fresh
in this world yeah I thought the arcs of everyone
were were fantastic about the leadership points
love splinters Arc I love them learning so
much from like watching television that's
something that I especially identify with
growing up and not really knowing how to be
I would often emulate or mirror personalities
I would see in movies and shows and I'm like
oh I really I I just really identified with
them this time yeah it was it was really cool
it was a really cool experience as I explained
too in the TMNT 2007 uh at the end in the
review the ultimate meta thing for me is I
learned how to do mouth to mouth CPR which
is what helped me which would help me save
my mother's life right after I watched the
third film so I learned a lot from these films
so yeah um which again I I can really relate
to how they're learning from that which is
because I learned from watching them so they
know what they're doing man yeah it's good
stuff it's good stuff good um but guys hey
um I thank you guys so much for uh being here
appreciate all the love appreciate all the
time Andrew thank you for being here thank
you for accepting or not accepting me drop
in the references it's okay I kind of accept
you now and hey let's end this with a patron
of the day shout out you know who I accept
Eric Horseman oh you know why accept Eric
Horseman because of my actual birthday he's
the only one who made an Instagram post about
me from the patrons here in the shout out
list Eric only one well done buddy he didn't
accept it he didn't but you did you were jerks
we're both Eric now I accept you my friend
and it is one of my life missions to make
it to Atlanta and then be able to hang out
with you buddy still have the real rejects
tattoo on there is that crazy oh my God that's
awesome I love you man and um just know that
if there's anyone here at the patreon that
I accept to you everyone else has still got
a while to go but you everyone's got a lot
of Instagram posts we've got the most accepted
in this heart right now buddy I love the hell
out of you I give you a big smooch on the
lips give you a big eat your meatballs
swallow your spaghetti give me that cream
sauce that Alfredo Eric Horseman this is what
this is to the tear
frauds
[Music]